Jim Gard is a math teacher at the school
and he taught the shooting suspect
Nicholas Cruz just last year he joins us
tonight mister guard thanks for coming
on oh well so you're the first person
we've spoken to who knew the suspect
personally he was in your class what was
your view of him well I think I only had
it for maybe a semester in 2000 uh
August and August and December of 2016
when I can remember I just don't look at
now but no it was in class I mean he was
real quiet I mean nothing nothing
outstanding I mean only about a couple
of emails you know here are there from
Adnan regarding Nick but I'd have to get
into my computer when I get home and
take a look at those emails anything
significant that I can remember it's
been over a year
well let me put it this way when you saw
his face on television and read his name
did you think I'm shocked by this or did
you think you know of the kids I teach
maybe this isn't the most surprising
suspect on television yet I you know we
were in lockdown and no TV's on or
anything like that and when I heard the
name from some of my students when we
were in the lockdown you know it hit me
it's like oh wow I had Nick in class I
was about to look him up and then the
police came and sought us out of our
room so am i shocked you know I hate to
say it nowadays with all these dolts
doing nothing shocking anymore and it
yes and that death horrible it is
horrible it's maybe the most horrible
part of all of the